god of war 2018 is coming to pc destiny
2 is charging extra for dungeons plus
we're gonna have to wait a little bit
longer for the updated versions of
cyberpunk and the witcher 3. my name is
devonte chisholm and you're watching
gamespot news
pc players rejoice you're finally going
to be able to play as kratos in a
non-fortnite form this is because 2018's
god of war is headed to the platform via
steam in january the game also features
full integration with nvidia's deep
learning super sampling aka dlss nvidia
reflex for better latency and support
for 20 by 9 ultra wide screens as well i
can't recommend this game enough if you
haven't played it and your pc only this
is the perfect chance jump in experience
it
be wowed
thank me later
switching gears to destiny 2 now because
bungie announced the game's new dungeons
in the witch queen expansion will cost
extra writing on reddit bungie's chris
shannon shared that the witch queens
digital deluxe edition comes with all
four seasons of content in 2022 and the
two new dungeons players who buy the
standard edition can pay for an upgrade
to the deluxe edition or they can buy
the dungeons separately however pricing
for the standalone dungeon access has
not been announced yet the reddit post
where shannon shared the information is
now flooded with negative comments and
while a fire is blazing within the
destiny community the no man's sky
community are thriving
hello games has announced a new
halloween event for no man's sky in the
form of expedition 4 emergence the
seasonal event which begins today will
feature a new narrative a first for the
game mode as well as several gameplay
features and enhancements in expedition
4 emergence players will find themselves
stranded on a planet which has been
ravaged by dust storms and infested with
titan worms the game will also add the
ability to tame and grow a sandworm
companion to feed pet ride and explore
the universe with they can also fly for
the full rundown on this new update make
sure to visit gamespot.com
and now for some unfortunate news as cd
projekt red has announced that the ps5
and xbox series x and s versions of
cyberpunk 2077 will release in q1 2022
followed by the witcher 3 wild hunt in
q2 of 2022 but keep in mind those who
already own the ps4 and xbox one
versions of cyberpunk and the witcher 3
are eligible for a free upgrade to the
new versions when they launch
but okay on october 20th bethesda
released a new video giving players a
look at the location they can expect to
explore in star field called the settled
systems according to the game's design
director the settle systems lie 50 light
years away from our current solar system
and 20 years before the start of the
game which takes place in 2330 there was
a bloody faction war between the united
colonies and the freestar collective and
while there is an uneasy peace in the
settled systems when the player's story
begins there are still threats to be
aware of starfield arrives exclusively
on xbox series x and s and pc on
november 11 2022.
so hit the comment section and let me
know if you've already played the 2018
god of war if you plan to play it over
again when it comes to pc like where do
you stand with the game and how excited
are you for ragnarok i'll see you
tomorrow